bill mollusion is live at the southern
border for us in la jolla texas with
more so bill i'm just always curious how
can a drug cartel assure a parent that
they can get their kid into our country
i mean is it that easy have we made it
that easy for them
harris good morning to you in parts of
the border it is that easy there's not a
border wall and agents can't be
everywhere at once they're completely
overwhelmed processing these family
units that pulls agents off the front
lines and there are parts of the border
where they're just flat out isn't
anybody patrolling and that's just the
case out here in la jolla sometimes take
a look at this video we shot earlier
this morning here once again as usual i
know i sound like a broken record but it
happens every day out here you get out
here and you see these family units who
have just crossed illegally into texas
here la jolla they walk down a road and
they give themselves up to border patrol
now these ones border patrol doesn't
have to go out into the brush to find
because they are voluntarily giving
themselves up because they believe
they'll be released into the u.s and
they have good reason to believe that
you just heard dhs secretary marcus say
his estimation is 375 000 have already
been released so far this year but you
can see with these groups mostly family
units unaccompanied teenagers a lot of
young kids that's exactly right the
cartels like to advertise on social
media that they can get kids across the
border into the usa back out here live
for a moment we met up with a woman
named christy hutchinson the other night
here in la jolla she's the founder of
women fighting for america this is a
group that throughout the
border crisis has gone to different
border towns and they work with law
enforcement they've got this really
sophisticated drone that helps track
down runners look at this video we were
here with them in la jolla the other
night using that drone it's got thermal
imaging didn't take long we found a
group of about five to six runners taken
off through the brush here after they
crossed illegally into texas now they
work with border patrol as that drone
was watching those migrants using that
thermal imaging they were relaying the
coordinates to border patrol agents on
the ground on horseback and on foot they
quickly closed in on those illegal
immigrants and because of the help of
that drone they were able to apprehend
every single one of those runners who
came across we talked to hutchinson
about why she feels the need to do this
she says she's a mom she's got two boys
and with the amount of drugs pouring
across the border she felt she had to do
her part take a listen
drug trafficking has gone up over 450
something percent that's a lot of drugs
coming and flooding into our streets as
a mother of uh two young adult boys that
that hits me really hard at home i mean
this is coming to your streets this is
in your neighborhoods uh the drugs don't
just stay here at the border within 42
to 72 hours they're in cities all across
the united states
and to her point we just learned from
the cdc today that for the first time in
american history they're estimating a
hundred thousand americans died in one
year of drug overdoses some of that of
course attributed to the rise in
fentanyl deaths as we know fentanyl
continues to just pour across the border
we'll send it back to you yeah i mean
you have to start to connect the dots
or as our vice president likes to say
look for the root causes of why this is
happening uh bill millusion thank you
very much hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now